ciao ragazzi come vi ho promesso nelle
mie storie instagram
ecco a voi il video per mostrarvi tutto
quello che quest'anno in questi giorni
di saldi parentesi come potete notare
sono treccia sicuramente vi chiederete
se me li sono fatti ma in realtà sono i
capelli quindi spero che vi piaccia
anche questa versione molto ma torniamo
allo shopping
era domenica 2 luglio qualche giorno fa
e dopo la palestra perché domenica stato
vuole sempre andare il cristo cominciamo
dalla palestra che erano già debole 8 e
andiamo in rinascente
per chi non lo sapesse la caccia in the
chiude alle 10 ovviamente siamo usciti
insieme a commesse abbia fatto oggi la
sura perché erano le 10 e 5 minuti in
tutto questo salvo fatto shopping e
mentre io sono andato a vedere le scarpe
e ho preso
partiamo dalle singer di adidas gli opa
d'oro sono tosti non sono mie erano al
50 quindi quasi subito e non vedo la
crisi a punto per la prima volta una
donna che si possono permettere perché
ovviamente adesso l'estate farlo con un
cammino però andiamo
ciao canali grazie per essere stati con
me in questa scelta di queste ciabatte
che definire con una parola sobria la
sobrietà prima di tutto una ciabatta
comunque che non vuole farsi notare
quest'estate in spiaggia sono la lady
gaga delle spiagge siciliane
perciò se vedete voi cosa luccicare
siete in sicilia mi avete appena testa è
così conclusa la giornata
domenica per marina e salvatore tutti e
due molto soddisfatti ma c'è un
dettaglio che vi voglio raccontare che
il motivo per cui lo shopping si è
protratto anche il giorno dopo mentre
stavamo uscendo eventi commessi ci
stavano prendendo a calci per farci
uscire facendo il parricidio per uscire
salvo visto delle ciabatte di armani se
non sbaglio però non abbiamo avuto tempo
di comprarle quindi l'ho visto un po
pranzo quando poco noti quella tristezza
negli occhi no allora ben sai cosa c'è
mi alzo di prima mattina soltanto per
andare lì nascente comprare le diciamo
che voleva pensate che tom pensa te
l'amore che lega queste due persone ma
come sempre nei saldi sarebbe stato
troppo bello che ci è stato il numero
del modello del colore che volevano qui
quindi niente c'erano altri modelli lei
solo per cui avviene tipo da cestista
quindi ancora 35 46 se volete fare un
regalo e
niente quindi cosa succede visto che ho
sempre l'ansia di sbagliare regalo che
mi dà fastidio commissario fotografato
tutti i colori che i modelli del lungo
la sua e che lo mandano lui mi ha
risposto così mi fido della mia testa e
ha fatto bene perché marino ha scelto un
total black
anche questa volta le fantasie di calvin
klein come potete vedere
per questo la prossima che la mia faccia
e non è poco dopo quindi le ciabatte di
saldo mi hanno portato alla rinascente
ha detto obiettivamente giacche sono non
me lo faccio un giro in montenapoleone
in quei negozi giusto per vedere le
vetrine perché sta che anche coi saldi e
cioè ti chiedono un rene e ho detto va
bene faccio questo giro
avete presente quando il cuore qui porta
in determinati posti ecco dio io mi sono
ritrovata davanti e prada perché il mio
cuore mi aveva portato lotti non so
neanche perché sembra ma infranto gli
dico ovviamente la parte dei saldi
dove sono i dati del banco sopra il
bancone con gli occhi a cuore mi sarà
vicino da meter a lei la corsa che stavo
cercando era uno cosentina mi farò
vedere che noi infatti seconda che siete
immaginati chissà che borsa dalle mie
storie
no non è un pò le borse enormi g20 casa
milan e ora la prenda in mano ed è
subito amore
ovvero quando chiesto il prezzo è finito
di chiedere il prezzo era di che la
guardando arriva dagli etero croci vi
faccio evidente di vita allora cappello
alla michele misseri proprio allo qui
sulla quarantina altra come meno matches
biggs e disprezzo della borsa che ho tra
le mani e l'ultima non sa fare gridare
in media niente le dice il prezzo come
sembra strappa dalle mani io già nero di
metropoli però cioè su questa kenya in
caso la compro io
c'è la d'agitazione nell'aria gliela ri
strappo della commessa praticamente e
niente si chiede inizia a crearsi la
pressione psicologica sul perche la
commessa di stampo china da chiedere ma
da prendere per intraprendere il volo
dire soldi cioè signora non si parla di
2 euro midal antinino tv per capire se
devo credevo fare le foto al kassar
volevo vederla tutta la famiglia
niente faccio le foto che quando stavo
ma salvo lavorando non mi risponde
quindi aumenta l'ansia perché i ruoli
che mi piacciono le moto lo specchio la
cinese che guardavano come se guarda e
nonostante questo c'è inoltre si è
formata una coda dietro perché c erano
altre persone però interessante proprio
quello borsa ma voglio che ci sono 700
borse in saldo ma pretende quelle c'è
ovviamente la più bella la prendo io non
mi sono mai sentita così [ __ ] paziente
c'eravamo tutti addosso poi guardava ma
io con la borsa in mano la prendono la
prendo mi arrivò al messaggio di salvo
amore e bellissima prende a mi sono
girata ho fatta così che capelli e un
tetto
la fretta ed è stato il panico perfino
accidenti
come fare allora fretta fatto che non ci
voleva proprio pagato fino a quel
momento mi trattava come se fosse nulla
compravo inventata ma c'è la carta del
padova è uguale regaleremo le borse
insomma bello molto bene vado alla cassa
e popolare borsa è stato un bel momento
ma cosa ha chiuso al momento è
finalmente la borsa la borsa che
attenderà defanti vedere qui
[Musica]
dopo diciotto detto no
per chi non conoscesse zanotti perché a
mente per comprarla serve di zanotti
vedere in lei
il fegato è un occhio belle per carità
ma molto molto proibitive
niente anche questa volta comunque non
proibitive la trovo bellissima mano le
foto saldo che ormai 200.000 quindi
neanche più mi calcolavano visualizzato
senza risposta della serie fai tu se
vuoi rovinare ha rovinati e niente vele
prova dolore lì ma certo punto come
sempre ragazzo e lo sapete quando non si
decida cosa di cc 25 minuti ma la
prendere un caffè
quindi avete letto vari facciamo così ci
pensa un attimo dopo
so che cazzata vivi dentro quindi visto
che l'avevo mangiare come canale 4
pomeriggio ancora digiuno artistico c'è
da chiedere cosa le dico no guardi in
realtà volevo anche mangiare qualcosina
quindi penso che andrò qua di fronte
oltre che ha sempre un tramezzino va
bene scampato cosa fare merenda
ovviamente non mi vedranno è perché ho
ragionato ragazzi questa è la parte
diciamo riflessiva del video vi sarete
ritrovato il parquet volte anche molti
questa situazione perche spendere tutti
quei soldi per una scarpa che quindi
conosce la sera mette imparando ad
avallare citate sopra il cocktail si
rovina il tappo e gli vengono cioè i
mancamenti non ha senso meglio comprare
una borsa che dicono di più la politica
umbri non saprei ma ho preso queste ho
preso queste altre soffrissi e scarpe
rigorosamente oro perché come sapete io
o nero oro nero come direbbe giorgia e
ho preso questa comoda pelle
foro sobria ovviamente si abbinano tutto
quello che ho letto la sera ai 50 già
pagate 90 euro
obiettivamente con un link tesimone
quarantesimo di qualità non può
accompagnare sono e comunque se mi vuoi
regalare delle scarpe l'indirizzo è via
protette teniamoci in contatto e poi
abbiamo bisogno di un sandalo nero
perché tutti gli anni per comprare uno
che appunto come dico io è nella scarpa
da battaglia che metto mano anche per
andare in sbianca fare il bagno la notte
ho preso queste qua marina che era anche
questa 50 pelle morbidissima semplice
sandalo nero regista come tutte le sere
ma non è finita ma non è finita qui
perché avevo anche un bisogno compulsivo
di uno zainetto nero possibilmente
perché ho seguito perché
avete se per chi gli zaini e zaini che
saranno il must della prossima stagione
inverno né a me fanno impazzire sotto
quelli carimini compatti per la domenica
quando ero consalvo rinascente ho visto
modello dimostrino in salto top
benissimo come forma tutto però
quindi ho detto no non lo prendo il
gioco dopo ribasso dallo stand di
moschino e rivedo perchè avevo comunque
il mezzo dubbio se vendono non prendersi
fare questa cagata che voi magari non
avrei mai messo quindi vanno dalla
commessa e come il giorno precedente
perché dico non si sa mai magari cade
una meteorite un meteorite è cambia il
colore dello zar
le chiedo ma quindi c'è solo rosso
domenica si piace sono rosso così lui di
questa commessa signorina c'è solo rosso
ce l'abbiamo anche in nero però la
scritta colorata o si sa barbieri il
giorno prima non avevano tanto nero
questa volta è vero ma ce l'aveva e
questo è lo zaino nero di moschino che
alla fine ho incontrato che è
praticamente come quello della
collezione
la nuova collezione solo che con
l'abolizione a questa scritta oro che si
sarebbe piaciuta di più ma costava un
rene anche questo invece questo l'ho
pagato 50 per cento una cifra non
accettabile in più per 1 0 dimostrino di
pelle nero carinissimo che metterò ok
abbiamo quindi il video che dice qui no
perché la vogliono vedere la borsa
voglio vedere la borsa cioè se è stato
creato così tanto hype dalla
sottoscritta per questa borsa che
sicuramente adesso vi farà schifo come
minimo perché sette giorni che aspettate
che stavolta ve lo dico ciao piccolina
anche perché più grande vendere tutti
lui e lei no solo uno è già vasto non me
la passo era procedere
dovete vedere
[Musica]
[Applauso]
eppure ha una pelle morbidissima erano
solo giorno di una cosa che mi affascina
delle borse che mi ha fatto appunto
decidere di comprarla la morbidezza
dietro potete capirmi vorrei che dai
video si potesse trattare ma non si può
quindi accontentatevi ed è la chiamerò
la chiamerò usa chiamano aiutatemi voi
scrive nei commenti come la posso
chiamare quindi ragazzi è stato un video
lungo ma doveroso perché doveroso era
doveroso farvi vedere mentre partecipi
tutte queste potevo comprato su spero
che piacciono potete sapere nei commenti
cosa che mi piace di più ma soprattutto
fatemi sapere chi e nome devo dare alla
mia nuova bambina pochi averi piaciuto
il video mette the like iscrivetevi al
canale e se tutti gli altri social tra
l'altro ha scoperto che musicali si dice
news italiano seguite tutti gli altri
social facebook instagram musicali e la
chance
[Musica]